god of thunder king khan
you have finally joined our fight well
they say better late than not alone
this is very nice
as you know we used to live in a
peaceful oasis but then our gods were
murdered murdered and now our sacred
temple has been left unguarded and
hopefully to control of its power it is
our most sacred shrine and it desecrates
not for long
king you can't
tell them what happened here today
tell us the time that thor
the drag tag motley crew misfit
desperados turn the tide in the battle
and that's their names in history the
odds may be against us but i'll tell you
this for free here we go this
and
here and now
they're in the shadow realm how do you
know
the atmosphere there has a darkness like
no other it's as if color feels to tread
it's unmistakable
well then if it's color we need
let's bring the rainbow
bring the rainbow with her catchphrase
or something she's only been a thor for
a minute i mean saving lives she's quite
good at but the rest of it she needs
work how many catchphrases have there
been a lot
yep
jump the gun hang on he moves through
shadows and he's going to the shadow
realm it seems like that's where he's
going to be the most powerful you're
right we can't just go marching in there
it could be a trap are you thinking what
i think you're thinking i'm thinking it
what are we thinking thinking we're
taking it too much
[Music]
you